Kelly hopkinson's Care Home has spare
beds
and the government thinks Care Homes
like hers can help to ease the NHS
winter crisis I do have quite a few
empty beds and I'm I'm willing to help
when we can
love you they want to move thousands of
free up hospital beds
Kelly says she's ready but no one has
called that could take to order you know
if I make sure I've got enough staff
I've got 17 empty beds sat there I've
had no contact I ain't had one inquiry
through today
so I don't know I don't know why they're
not making contact if they're under that
much pressure
Steve Barkley hopes these measures will
ease pressure on a buckling Health
Service and that's some of the 13
000 people across England occupying
hospital beds despite being medically
fit to discharge can now be moved safely
into the community we will block book
beds in residential homes to enable
around 2 500 people to be released from
hospitals where they are medically fit
to be discharged when combined with the
ramping up of the 500 million discharge
funding
it will unblock which will unblock an
estimated one to two thousand delayed
discharge cases capacity on Wards will
be freed up Health leaders say the
government's move fails to address the
root cause a Workforce crisis in the
Health and Social care sectors although
people might not need treatment for the
reason they came into hospital no any
longer they still have multiple
comorbidities so multiple illnesses they
might have Frailty or dementia and
putting these patients who might need
ongoing Medical Care putting them into a
social care setting puts more pressure
on that sector absolutely so we know
that particularly District nursing
services are really really very
stretched and so is general practice
there are serious issues in capacity and
those are the workforces that would
generally look after people in the home
the move will create some desperately
needed capacity but the warning for the
government is that this is a short-term
fix at best and not a long-term solution
for the NHS
Ashish Joshi Sky News